[موسيقى]
الناس كالطيور والطيور على اشكالها تقع
لكن الطيور تستطيع غالبا تنظيم اجتماع
نوعها فالنسور لا تصطاد النسور ولا تكيدوا
البلابل لعشيرتها اما البشر فيميلون في
بدايه الامر الى التجمع على اساس عرقي
فنجد حيا ارمنيا مثلا او صينيا في مدينه
كبيره
واخر للايطاليين وشوارع للعرب وغيرهم ثم
تسال احد السكان عن ازماته فيقول جاري يا
مزعج وعصابه الحي افسدت ابنه وسياره سرقت
من تحت بيتي وكل ذلك فعله بنو قومه
لتتحطم بلحظه كل دعوات الانغلاق العرقي
والصفاء القومي والعصبيه الطائفيه لصالح
قيم تجمع
وتلخصها الايه القرانيه يا ايها الناس انا
خلقناكم من ذكر وانثى
وجعلناكم شعوبا وقبائل لتعارفوا ان اكرمكم
عند الله اتقاكم ان الله عليم خبير صدق
الله العظيم الى العناوين
ارض فرنسا او انسحابها من النيجر يتحقق
باعلان باريس
ماكرون يحضر العباءه على المسلمات ويلبسها
لزوجته
حمدتي يتحدث عن حكم ديمقراطي بهيج
والبرهان يطالب بتصنيفه ارهابيا
للجادين فقط اعصار دانيال صنع للانتقام من
خليفه حفتر
الاسد في رحله عائليه الى الصين بحضور ملك
كمبوديا
العنصريون يشبهون اللاجئين بالنفايات
واردوغان يبدا حمله عليهم
شاب مصري اخرس ينطق بالقران الكريم فقط
[موسيقى]
مرحبا هل تريدون ان تصبحوا محللين سياسيين
انه درب طويل يبدا بالقراءه ثم القراءه ثم
الاستماع ولا ينتهي بالربط والمقارنه
والاستنتاج لكن لكل مهنه سوق سوداء غير
نظاميه او علميه والسوق السوداء للتحليل
السياسي بحسب بهيجو هي ان تستمع لمنويل
ماكرون شو بيقول قول عكسه وانا بضمن لك
انه الجزيره والسي ان ان يتصلوا فيك
ويقولوا لك يا عمي انت كيف بتعرف
الرئيس ماكرون سعى لان يكون وسيطه سلام
بين روسيا واوكرانيا فرفض الرئيس بوتين
وسططه واجلسه بعيدا عنه امام الطاوله
الشهيره
ماكرون وعد اللبنانيين بالمن والسلوى
وانقاذ اقتصادهم وعملتهم الوطنيه لينتهي
به الامر الى مساعده ماليه صغيره للمدارس
الكاثوليكيه اللبنانيه دون غيرها
والاسوا دائما في تصريحات ماكرون ادعائه
ان الاسلام يعيش ازمه في كل مكان فيما
ازمات فرنسا عاصفه حتى في داخلها ومؤخرا
شدد وردد وكرر ماكرون بانه لا يستجيب
لقرار النظام العسكري المنقلب في النيجر
بطرد سفيره والقوات الفرنسيه من البلاد
لكنه وقف قبل يومين بكل ثقه معلنا جلاء
سفيره وعسكره عن ارض النيجر الجميله
لتلتحق بشقيقاتها الافريقيه ضمن موجه طرد
فرنسا من القاره السمراء التقرير التالي
من قناه الجزائر الدوليه
خاضعا مستسلما للامر الواقع يعلن الرئيس
الفرنسي قرار سحب سفير بلاده وقواتها
العسكريه من النيجر بعد قرابه شهرين
كاملين من تمسك باريس بالبقاء في النيامي
رغم دعوات المجلس العسكري الانسحابها حينا
وتحديدها بالطرد حينا
قررت فرنسا اعاده سفيرها ولذا سيعود
سفيرون مع عدد من الدبلوماسيين الى فرنسا
في الساعات المقبله سننهي التعاون العسكري
مع سلطات الامر الواقع في النيجر في
الاسابيع والاشهر المقبله انها لم تعد
ترغب في مكافحه الارهاب وبالتالي فان ذلك
يعني نهايه الوجود العسكريه الفرنسي في
النيجر المجلس العسكري في النيجر يعتمد
القسوه في خطابه ويقول للفرنسيين
بارادتكم او بالقوه ستخرج رحب المجلس
العسكري في النيجر باعلان فرنسا اعتزامها
سحب قواتها من البلاد بحلول نهايه العام
واعتبر المجلس ان كل من يهدد مصالح واراده
النيجر يجب عليه الخروج منها سواء كان ذلك
بارادته ام لا مضيفا ان القوات
الامبرياليه والاستعماريه الجديده غير
مرحب بها على اراضي النيجر الامين العام
للامم المتحده انطونيو غوتيريوس ينتقد
باللغه الفرنسيه
التمييز الذي تمارسه فرنسا ضد لباس النساء
المسلمات
ويقارد بين دول تمنع خ الالبسه واخرى تمنع
ارتدائها واضعا اياها في خانه واحده
لفاميلي
مسلسل مسلسل التناقضات المكرونيه لا يتوقف
فبعد حظره العباءه على المسلمات في مدارس
فرنسا يظهر ماكرون مع عقيلته ابريجيت وهي
ترتدي عباءه تغطي كامل جسدها افلا يعتبر
ذلك مخالفا لتقاليد المجتمع الفرنسي
اللايك العلماني ام ان ماكرون لا يريد ان
تتعلمن زوجته بريزيت في فرنسا يرسمون
ماكرون في الكاريكاتير بانف طويل جدا
تشبيها له بنجم الرسوم المتحركه بينوكيو
الذي كان انفه يزداد طولا كلما كذب على
الناس واستغل معارضوه طول انفه لاظهار
اشتيائهم من سياسته وفي سياق التناقضات
ايضا لفتت قناه فرانس 24 تحت عنوان محايد
دينيا الى ان حضور الرئيس الفرنسي القداس
الذي تراسه البابا فرنسيس في مارسيليا
اثارا انتقادات المعارضه الفرنسيه ضد
ماكرون الذي لم يلتزم بالحياد الديني بحسب
المعارضه محايد دينيا لكنه لا يتاخر عن
المشاركه في المناسبات الدينيه رئيس قد
يصدم دعاه العلمانيه التي نشات في فرنسا
عام 1905
العلاقه بين الكنيسه والدوله تدهورت
واصلاحها يقع على عاتقه احزاب اليسار وعلى
راسها حزب فرنسابيه ترى ان الرئيس بحضوره
القداسه ينتهك مبدا الفصل بين الدين
والدوله الذي يمثل اساس قانون عام 1905
البابا ذاته لم يطلب منه شيئا ولم يكن حتى
في زياره دوله وانما في زياره ذات طابع
ديني صرف حضور ماكرون قداس البابا راته
اطياف اليسار خلالا بحياد الدوله دينيا
لكن ماكرون يقول انه لم يذهب الى القداس
بوصفه كاثوليكيا وانما كرئيس لجمهوريه
علمانيه كل هذا الانتقاد للسلطات الفرنسيه
لا يحجب حقيقه عن باريس وهي انها تعيش
ديمقراطيه سياسيه متقدمه لا نعيشها في
معظم دولنا تعبر فيها المعارضه السياسيه
عن مواقفها بكل حريه والاعلام الفرنسي
الرسمي اعلام عام وليس اعلام سلطه ومنه
غالبا نقرا المشهد الفرنسي في برنامجنا
كما تشاهدون
فسبوبا لهذا النوع من الحريه التي يحق
ايضا لشعوب افريقيا ان تعيشها
[موسيقى]
بحسب البنك الدولي فان
25% من الفلسطينيين داخل فلسطين باتوا تحت
خط الفقر مع بدايه تفشي اقصى التطرف
الطائفي داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه
25% من الفلسطينيين يعيشون تحت خط الفقر
هذا ما خلص اليه تقيع للملك الدولي متوقعا
تواصل سوء الاوضاع الفلسطينيه بسبب تضاؤل
حجم الاقتصاد المحلي وسط حصار
الاسرائيليين خانق حصار الاحتلال وفساد
بعض السلطه في رام الله رفع نسبه الغارقين
في الفقر الى ربع الفلسطينيين بينما
استطاعت المنظومه السياسيه الحاكمه في
لبنان ان تجعل ثمانين بالمئه من
اللبنانيين تحت خط الفقر وباعتراف وزاره
الخارجيه اللبنانيه هذه المقارنه بين
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي والفساد اللبناني
الرسمي لا تبيض وجه الاحتلال الاسود باي
حال بل تزيد وجه الفساد حلكه في لبنان
نستمع الى مقطع للمطربه جوليا بطرس التي
غنت لكل ثورات الارض الا ثوره شعبها على
المنظومه الحاكمه الاثار
[موسيقى]
ان حياتك وقد عز تتغير فيها
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا ايرلابيد
الذي يعتبره المتشددون حمامه سلام مائعه
بل هو مشغول منذ الان من امكانيه تخصيب
السعوديه في المستقبل
لليورانيوم ويربط بين السعوديه ومصر
وتركيا بمعيار الخطوره على اسرائيل واضاف
انه يجب عدم السماح للسعوديين بتخصيب
اليورينيوم واشار لبيد الى ان تخصيب
اليورينيوم في السعوديه سيشكل خطرا على
اسرائيل وسيقود الى سباق تسلح في الشرق
الاوسط حيث سترغب تركيا ومصر بعد ذلك في
الدخول في عمليه التخصيب النووي
قالوا عنه انه متوفى وان شبحه هو الذي
يتكلم بتقنيه الذكاء الاصطناعي فرد مرارا
بانه حي يسعى بل وجه كلمه بصوت والصوره
مؤخرا الى الامم المتحده قائد قوات الدعم
السريع الجنرال حميتي يطالب بحكم ديمقراطي
بهيج في السودان
ان يكون ديمقراطيا مدنيا يضم الانتخ
ابات وهكذا يكون الاستاذ حمتي ثانيا اكثر
رجلين عربيين في العالم تحدثا عن حقوق
الانسان بعد الدبلوماسي اللبناني شارل
مالك الذي شارك في صياغه الاعلان العالمي
لحقوق الانسان اذا للسودان صوتان يخزي
العين بدل الصوت الواحد صوت طائر غير رسمي
لحميتي وحضور كامل لرئيس مجلس السياده
الجنرال عبد الفتاح البرهان في نيويورك
الذي طالب المجتمع الدولي
بتصنيف قوات الدعم السريع تنظيما ارهابيا
معتبرا ان حميتي بات يشكل خطرا على العالم
متلو مثل السلاح النووي يطالبكم السيد
الرئيس
والمجتمع الدولي باعتبار هذه القوات
والمجموعات المتحالفه معها مجموعات
ارهابيه
تستوجب ان يقف الجميع في وجهها
ويحاربها لحمايه الشعب السوداني
والاقليم بلوى العالم عندما يختلط التحليل
السياسي بالتنجيم المغربي والتخبيص
الجيولوجي والتطويل الفضائي ويوضع على نار
خفيفه نحصل على وصفه جديده لاعصار دانيال
لقد صنع في الغرب للانتقام من خليفه حفتر
اعصار دانيال على انه اعصار غير غير طبيعي
غير طبيعيه الحدوث هكذا اسلحه طيب الان
هناك سلاح سلاح يسمى سلاح الطقس لان
للمكان في شمال افريقيا وليبيا ولا
التوقيت هو مناسب لهطول هذه الكميات من
الامطار ساندي واعصار كاترينا
ما ماتوش فيه اكثر من 1800 كيف في في درنه
يموتوا 15 الف و20 على فكره حيفوت الرقم
20,000 وبالتالي عندما نتكلم عن اشياء يجب
ان تاخذ بعين الاعتبار دوله يجب تعرف
العالم وين وصل الاعصاب كان متوجه مباشره
الى مدينه بنغازي وانا اعتقد مزازما ان
هذا مكان يراد يراد يراد ان هذا الاعصار
ان ينهي مشروع الدوله في مدينه بنغازينا
فنيه تقنيه الاعصار حوله الله عز وجل عن
بنغا الرئيس السوري بشار الاسد وزوجته
واولاده يقومون بزياره عائليه للصين
يحضرون خلالها الى جانب ملك كمبوديا حفله
افتتاح دوره الالعاب الاسيويه زياره الاسد
ساقت الكثير من التكهنات عما يقف وراءها
وعن الغايه منها فالاسد حضر حفل افتتاح
دوره الالعاب الاسيويه برفقه ملك كمبوديا
وولي العهد الكويتي ورئيس الوزراء
النيبالي ورئيس وزراء تيمور الشرقيه ورئيس
وزراء كوريا الجنوبيه لكنه الوحيد من اتى
بصحبه زوجته واولاده ما فتح الباب لسؤال
يطرح كثيرا هل اتى الاسد للتنزه في الصين
[موسيقى]
في الرد على موجه العنصريه في تركيا ضد
المهاجرين واللاجئين والسياح العرب ذهب
بعض العرب بعيدا ووضعوا الشعب التركي في
سله واحده علما ان العنصريين لا يمثلون كل
تركيا حتى ان راس حربه العنصريه اوميت
اوزداد لم يستطع هو وحزبه المغمور ان
يفوزوا بمقعد نيابي واحد في الانتخابات
الاخيره من يريد العرب خارج تركيا يريد
الاتراك ايضا خارج تركيا اذا كانوا مثل
هذا الشيخ الجليل الذي طلب منه علماني
استبدادي اي هاجر الى السعوديه فكيف رد
الشيخ عليه
يلا
الجيه مصطلح لبناني يعني زباله النفايات
ويحدث احيانا لغط بالسمع بين كلمتي جيه
وجيد ميرال اكسينار زعيمه حزب الجيد
التركيه العلمانيه المعارض جمعت بين
المصطلحين جيد وجيد وتنمرت على اللاجئين
حيث قالت عن الانتخابات البلديه القادمه
سننقذ ازمير من الروائح واللاجئين
[تصفيق]
تركي رجب طيب اردوغان يدرك ان الحمله
العنصريه المستعره ضد العرب والمسلمين في
تركيا هدفها قبيل الانتخابات البلديه
اظهار تحالفه الانتخابي وكانه يفضل
اللاجئين والغرباء على مصالح الاتراك هو
يريد ان يطبق القانون الذي يحضر العنصريه
دون ان يقدم في الوقت نفسه
للمعرضه دفعا انتخابيا فاقتصرت الاعتقالات
الاخيره التي نفذتها الشرطه التركيه على
صغار العنصريين ذلك هو تحليل سياسي تركي
فهل هو مقنع برايكم
دونوا ان رغبتم تركيا تعلن الحرب على
العنصريه
[موسيقى]
اعتقالات بالجمله وحمله تحقيقات واسعه ضد
مروجي الكراهيه ومعاداه الاجانب ويقول
الخبراء كذلك ان اعتقال صغار المحرضين
توجه نحو الطريق الصحيح لكنه يبقى غير كاف
في ظل وجود محرضين كبار لا يزالون هم
المحرك الاساسي لشعله الفتنه نجم الاسبوع
شاب غني يعبر سته بلدان على دراجه لاجل
تعلم الدين الحنيف في الازهر الشريف في
اجل حلمي
لعلم الدين تربت عيالي
زوجتي
وبنتي تركتهما في غينيا وركبت في على عجله
وجئت من غينيا الى تشاد الحمد لله انا
اليوم انا في مصر كنت انام في الغابات في
الجبال
وراسه على الانقله وصلت الى مصر
في صحه وذهبت الى ازهر الشريف وقدمت لهم
كل اوراق الحمد لله
اخذوني لو ما كان عندي
عجله
ساتي بقدمه بعلمه لعلم الدين انا انا
مستعد واجاهد صديقنا الغني مستعد لاي يقطع
نصف افريقيا على قدميه لاجل تلقي علوم
الدين وبعض الناس تاتيهم العلوم الى
بيوتهم لكنهم يفضلون اغاني عمرو دياب على
ارث عمرو بن العاص تعرف سوره الاخلاص ما
الصراحه مش عارفه بس مش مش فاكره دلوقتي
حاجه معينه انت لو قلت بدايه سوره الاخلاص
انا هكمل انا اكيد بس مش عارف الاسم عايز
البدايه وانت تكمل مش حوار البدايه هو
الاسم بس اللي بيقع مننا عامه انت عارفه
سوره الاخلاص مثلا بصراحه لا تعرف سوره
الاخلاط
الاخلاص لا مش حفظت انا اقرا القران بس مش
حافظ بعض ايات بس مش حافظ مش حافظ اه احنا
في غفله اسلاميه يقول رسول الله محمد عليه
الصلاه والسلام
اغتنم خمسا قبل خمس شبابك قبل هرمك وصحتك
قبل سقمك وغناك قبل فقرك وفراغك قبل شغلك
وحياتك قبل موتك يوسف فوزي الممثل المصري
الذي يوصف بالمحافظ يقدم نصيحه للشباب
بطريقه غير مباشره بعد عشر سنوات من
اصابته بالشلل الرعاش صلاه الفجر امنيته
الان
وتذكره ايات القران الكريم
دماغك لما بتشتغل بتشتغل في ايه بتفكر في
ايه
[موسيقى]
صلاه الفجر
انسى المصيبه
انه يروح اتجاه الازهر
قل هو الله احد ما توفي القصه الاخيره في
الحلقه ليست عاديه ابدا
وموثقه من جانب وزاره الصحه المصريه التي
تفيد ان الشاب عبد الكريم اخرس غير قادر
على النطق بتاتا بعد تعرضه لحادث ماساوي
اودى بحياه معظم افراد اسرته لكن المفاجاه
او الكرامه هي ان عبد الكريم الحافظه
لكتاب الله قبل الحادثه يستطيع الان ان
يقرا القران الكريم فقط بحسب التقرير
والمقابله التلفزيونيه حضرتك يفتح المصحف
يقرا يقفل المصحف ما فيش تواشيح الدينيه
ممكن تقولها بصوتك
انت شفت حاجه معينه خليتك تبقى كده
ممكن تترجم
رؤيه يعني في المنام
وافتح المصحف ليس البر
وانتم
تولوا وجوهكم قبل المشرق والمغرب
ولكن
البر من امن بالله واليوم الاخر والم
[موسيقى]
اولئك يعني لولا ان انا كمان معي تقرير
طبي
بيقولوا ما بيتكلمش
من وزاره الصحه المصريه اخيرا بقي ان نعرف
طبيعه الحادثه التي اودت بحياتي والدي عبد
الكريم ومعظم اشقائه رحمهم الله وافقدته
النطقة الا بالقران وقفت قدام حكايه
انسانيه صعبه وغريبه ومؤلمه حكايه اسره
تعرضت لحادث راح ضحيته الاب والام وسبعه
من الابناء ولم ينجو من الحادث سوى بطل
قصتنا
عبد الكريم
وتلاته من اخواته لكن يشاء القدر ان يؤثر
الحادث على عبد الكريم ففقد القدره على
النطق تماما اما المفاجاه فهي انه بيتكلم
فقط
وينطق بايه القران الكريم
[موسيقى]
ختاما في العمل الشريف لا توجد مهنه وضيعه
ومهنه راقيه بل يوجد انسان راقي وانسان
وضيع الحياه ليست ورقه يا نصيب اما تصيب
واما تخيب بل هي رزق من السماء وسعي في
الارض وفي الارض لا يوجد من يمشي عنك بل
يوجد من يعبد لك الطريق
لتجتازها انت على رجليك في دراستك وعملك
ومجتمعك اذا بقيت مكانك دون حركه ستنمو
على مياهك الراكده الطحالب واذا رجعت الى
الوراء
سيتجاوزك الزمن اما اذا تقدمت الى الامام
فلا تستعجل الوصول يكفي انك في الطريق
الصحيح ابدا صغيرا لا يهم فالشجره العصيه
على الرياح كانت بذره خير النديه
لا تخجل من العمل الحلال فهذه فتاه تركيه
اشتغلت عامله نظافه في مستشفى جامعي وصارت
الان طالبه على مقاعدها لتكون طبيبه في
المستقبل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
يا شباب